Hey everyone Diavolo here and today
we are back for the 2nd part of my
Solo leveling series coverage! As the
name says, the re-awakening arc kicks
straight back off after Jin, the final
member from the raid to remain inside,
survived the D-Rank Double Dungeon. This shorter
but extremely important arc delves more into the
world that we now find ourselves in. The weird
system that Jin discovered in the final moments
of the raid is elaborated on and our man finally
starts to make an attempt to get even stronger!
Before we get to that though, if you are new
around here and want to watch a bunch of similar
arcs for a variety of different series, then
subscribe as it really helps out with pushing
my content to a bunch of new amazing people!
Ofcourse if you want even more solo leveling,
then push this video to 3000 likes so I
know you all want the next arc! Either way,
sit back and relax as we delve into the
re-awakening arc from Solo Leveling.
Chapter 11
All of a sudden waking up in a hospital
bed, Jin sits up and gasps while grabbing
his previously fatally wounded chest. Panicked
and not really understanding what's going on,
he just assumes everything that just happened
was a dream. Questioning if it truly was a dream,
Jin turns to look outside and see’s
that he is indeed in hospital.
Closing the door behind them, two random guys
enter Jin's room and make their way over to
him! Wondering who they are, the man apologizes
for startling him while handing out his card.
Seeing that it reads ‘Korean Hunter Guild
Inspector’ Jin asks why it is they came to
see him. After a short chat, Jin is blown away to
find out he was unconscious for 3 entire days. He
quickly asks about the current state of Joohee and
Mr Song and is told they’re safe. However, due to
Song losing his arm, it will most likely impede
him from his work as a hunter and he may need to
retire. When it comes to Lee Ju-Hee, apparently
she is still being treated in hospital due to the
extreme trauma she faced. Right now its uncertain
if either of them will continue as hunters.
Continuing, the inspector goes to talk about
Kim and the other 2 who escaped aswell, but
Jin refuses to hear any more info. Obviously this
is due to how he despises the 3 people who chose
themselves over others and didnt even take the
time to think about what he might lose if he dies.
Its revealed that like we assumed, only 6 of the
original 17 members made it out alive. Being a
hunter is an extremely dangerous job, still its
rare for a massacre like this to occur. Once
the inspectors and white tiger guilds did reach
the scene, everything was gone. Instead all they
found was Jin lying atop the altar. No statues
or anything that the other 5 members described.
Blown away and unable to believe its
true, the inspector the same feelings,
he truly couldn't believe it either.
If it wasn't for the testimonies of
everyone else who survived, or
if some of the deceased weren't
found. The guild would’ve come to
a completely different explanation.
Leaning in close to our boy, the inspector
says that this is all just a theory,
however they all believe that he has
received the ‘double awakening’. Stunned
and more or less confused with what
a double awakening is, Jin inquires?
So inside of Solo Leveling, when
someone awakens for the first time,
their power level is SET and it cannot move. On
odd occasions though some hunters get awakened
again, after the first time. Through out the
last 10 years there has been a few cases of
C-Ranks shooting to A, or B or sometimes
even going all the way through to S-Rank.
Placing the magical detector on Jin’s bedside
table, the inspector explains that all Jin has
to do is place his hand on the mana crystal. The
inspector suspects that if like everyone
said, there were monsters with the ability
to one shot people. Normal hunters wouldn't
be able to survive, only by getting A and S
rank hunters would the situation have been
resolved. Still all the monsters ended up
disappearing. To him it would just be
stupid to not suspect the possibility
of Jin-woo recieving a double awakening, as
after all he was the only one left inside.
Sadly as the crystal finishes calculating the
strength of Jin, it reads back a power level of
only 10. Depressed, the inspector thinks
that trash is trash through and through,
like even the lowest E-Rank is a
70. Wondering what the result was,
Jin is told that it looks as if they
suspected him for absolutely no reason.
Watching the two guys leave now, Jin a little
bumbed that he didnt surge up in strength,
asks himself if the inspectors were aware of this
thing. Looking up at his random screen he
assumes they mustn't be able to see it.
What's weirder is that his torn off foot has
returned and the huge gash in his chest is
all back to normal. Its hard to tell what was
a dream and what was reality. He guesses that
maybe he should have told the inspectors he
can see this random screen. Yet before he
can dwell on his thoughts any longer, HIS
BANGING SISTER enters the room and asks
if his head wasn't hit aswell, cause wtf
is he actually doing pointing at the sky.
She asks him why it is that everyone else all
returned fine, but somehow he was the only one
who got injured. looking at his sister raging
out at him, Jin cant believe he almost left
her... Speaking up he asks if she’s able to see
the screen infront of him? Not knowing what he’s
on about, Jin explains it like when there’s an
unread mail box in a phone game. Curious if he
really did smack his head, she tells him that
well you’d first have to open the mail box...
Asking the mailbox to open, the screen infront of
Jin changes to now show him the unread message.
“welcome player. Daily Quest; preparing to
become strong has arrived... Leaving for now,
Jin's sister tells him she’s off
before gaping it with her mate.
Suddenly the screen starts
explaining to Jin that the
system will help the platers growth. Yet
if he fails to obey the systems orders,
there may be a penalty. For the
meantime, his rewards have arrived!
Not understanding a damn thing yet, Jin thinks
back and remembers the final moments from the
double dungeon where the screen first
appeared. Getting another notification,
Jins see’s his daily request
and decides to open the message.
Opening a directions screen now, it shows
that in order to complete the Daily Quest.
Jin will need to do 100 push ups, 100 curl
ups twice, 100 squats and a 10km run. Oml I
love how similar his quest plan is to Saitama’s
workout routine hahaha. There was this meme I
saw yesterday that represented this moment
perfectly, ill try find it haha. Anyways!
Assuming this entire screen thing
infront of him is just a joke,
Jin lays back down thinking that a
hospitalized person doesn't have the
strength to do that! Instead he’ll
check it after he gets some rest.
With Jin asleep, time slowly begins ticking
away until all of a sudden an alarm rings,
signaling to him that he has not
completed the daily quest. Due to
this it is now forcefully sending him towards
the penalty zone for an unspecified time limit.
Slowly waking up to the sound of the alarm, Jin's
room suddenly begins shaking and the soft blue bed
he was laying on, turns to stone, before then
turning into sand.... Sitting there looking
out over the desert plains, Jin panicked wonders
where the hell he is. Behind him a mound of sand
appears but he doesn't hear it as at the same
time he assumes that this was all just a dream.
As the shade of the sand mound hits him,
his head snaps back to see a poison fanged
giant sand centipede darting right at him.
Obscuring his vision, his quest directions pop
up showing that this penalty is one he needs
to survive for a time limit of four hours.
Chapter 12
Sweating and having pushed himself to
the limit for the past almost four hours,
Jin sprints in a hope that the ravenous
centipede behind him doesn't catch him.
Bringing him a level of peace, the alarm rings
signaling that he only has 7 more seconds to go!
As soon as the clock hits 437am another signal
appears, congratulating him on completing the
penalty quest. Jumping forth, Jin travels
through dimensions to fall back onto the
floor of his hospital room absolutely
knackered. Looking up the screen once
again changes asking if he would like to accept
his rewards for completing the penalty quest.
Unable to make a decision, Jin collapses from
exhaustion. Moments later a nurse enters the
room and screams out in shock, wondering what
in the world just happened here! As she yells
out for someone to give her a hand, we see
that Jin is laying helpless on the floor,
with a bunch of the deserts
sand dispersed out around him.
The next morning, two nurses are seen
gossiping about Jin-woo. From what
they’ve heard he’s a hunter and even though
its only been a few days since he awoke,
Jin has been running ever since. According to
the doctor this is because Hunters naturally
heal faster than normal people. So light
exercise should be absolutely fine for him!
Looking out the window, one of the girls
points out that even now he’s running!
Since Jin first woke back up its been
4 days and in that time he was able to
figure out a few things. Firstly, the
screen he can see is no an illusion.
Although nobody else can see it,
its clearly infront of his eyes!
Having completed his daily quest,
the rewards tab is then shown,
giving Jin a choice between 3 different
rewards. Choosing status recovery,
out boy is suddenly engulfed in a healing
light. This magic is somehow able to heal
the fatigue someone feels after exercising.
It doesn't matter how fatigued they are,
it will make the person feel as if they never
worked out to start with. On top of that,
there are also stat points and random boxed items.
The player can increase anyone of their stats at
will as long as you have some stat points. The
more Jin adds to his character stats the stronger
he naturally gets. If he increases a full level,
it also buffs every stat overall slightly. He now
has access to a status screen, skills screen and
inventory or item storage, its as if he’s playing
some sort of game being controlled by a random
phenomenon. Sitting outside the hospital on one
of the benches with a big smile on his face, Jin
curiously wonders what's even happening here.
Later that evening, Jin makes his way to
the reception and asks if its possible to
take a leave for today? Telling him its fine,
but still needing to now where he’s headed,
Jin explains that he needs to take
care of some business outside!
Making his way to HapJung Station level 3,
Jin stands above the staircase and readies
himself for what he intends to do. Pulling out
a key and remarking that its time to find out
what this thing does. We find that Jin got
this key as a reward from one of the boxes,
however this key seems slightly different
to the other ones he’s used at the hospital.
Instead of something that gives him
just bandages, this key has an item
class of E and apparently allows the user to
create something called an instant dungeon.
Quests, status windows, random rewards, Jin
assumes that this really might be all because
of that silly old double awakening, or perhaps a
procedure towards gaining it! If thats the case,
then he thinks its defiantly worth
trying! Most would laugh if they heard,
but the worlds weakest hero receiving a double
awakening seems plausible. After the previous
4 days work, Jin feels confident in his
ability to run, so if anything does look
like its gonna become dangerous. Jin's
plan is to turn and run no matter what!
Pushing the key forth and activating the instant
dungeon, a light of swirling blue energy appears
before him. Expanding in size almost immediately,
it opens a gateway into another world.
Unlike last time, Jin walks straight forwards
with no hesitation and makes his entrance into
the instant dungeon. Inside now, an alarm
rings out signaling that he has entered
the dungeon. Turning around, his previous
plans of fleeing in the sight of danger,
erode away as instead of an accessible
gateway, it has been sealed off.
Banging on the exit to the dungeon, Jin looks to
his side to watch a random female on her phone
casually walk through the sealed off gateway.
Confused because this is completely different
from the normal dungeons, Jin thinks that surely
it should be similar to the red gate. For those
confused because we dont even get into what a
red gate is for like 30 more chapters, a Red
Gate differs from a normal gate in that it seals
off its entrance once someone walks through it,
trapping the humans already inside the gate
and preventing anyone else from the outside
from entering the gate. This red gate will also
refuses to open until one of three things happen:
the boss is defeated, the entire raid party
is killed, or a dungeon break occurs. Anyways
thats enough for now, dont wanna get
to caught up on Red Gates JUST YET!
Trying to think of a different plan of action,
Jin's mind is interrupted as the alarm
sounds once more, telling him that he
cannot leave until either the boss is
killed or he uses the return crystal.
Sweating balls and unable to think of a way ahead,
Jin feels an ominous aura emanating from something
nearby in the darkness. Scared he asks himself if
he can really manage this dungeon without a party?
Bang, so what do you all think? im curious on
what rank this dungeon may be. Its a blue gate
thats had some glitchyness happen with it, if
it was like a red one it would have the same
stipulations, but it doesn't, but who
knows let me know your thoughts down
below. Obviously if you have enjoyed the
video then hit that like button and help
push it to 3000 likes so I know you want the
next part! Also if you are new around here,
then subscribe as it really helps out with pushing
my stuff to some new amazing people. Either way
for now its been your professional degenerate
Diavolo and ill see you all in a bit bye!